this is my 23rd season breeding brassica
vegetables an effort that started mostly
with cabbage
and one that's morphed mostly into leafy
greens and
broccoli over the last 20 to 23 years
the
leafy green interest started around 2008
we were doing green bean work in
eastern africa with charles's phd
and seeing the importance of african
kale
and how that link to efforts we had
amongst the brassicas really started to
kick that off
the effort was helped with an academic
venture fund
support from the atkinson center
and that focused on trying to diversify
leafy greens in africa where we started
to look at
a lot of the
a lot of the market classes
that are available including the boracal
types cards and portuguese truncuda and
toscano types
so that involved
testing materials in kenya and tanzania
and getting a feel for some of the
diversity that exists amongst the
brassica leafy greens which is
considerable
that um
led initially into testing a lot of the
collard collection from the usda around
2009
2010
i'm trying to identify some
unique quality traits within that
collection
uh that led to
selecting some golden colors out of the
cabbage colored types in that collection
and over time moving the golden leaf
color into the curly
flatten survive types that are more
indicative of the kel markets
we also initiated around 2012 efforts on
natural colors from brassica
uh this was really identified in high
amphis ion and materials
ones that
form desirable colors into the ph six to
eight
range
and brassicas are very high in
cyanidants
so we basically initiated efforts
in
the golden leaf
leafy greens
and in the high anthocyanin
purple materials
the popularity of kale over that time
has
increased
dramatically
this started around 10 years ago
and the reasons for it are multiple it's
a very versatile vegetable
uh it's got more texture and integrity
so it's a better component for
chips and smoothies
also makes an alternative base for
salads that can typically be more
complex
it's also noted for having high levels
of vitamins and minerals
the types that have
become more popularized in the us are
the
uh the curly types and the toscano types
they both have high levels of
leaf texture
and that gives a
number of benefits in the market it
provides a crunch rather than a crisp
than you get from lettuce
it provides a lot of volume in the salad
by giving it the shape characteristics
and of course it gives it the ability to
hold dressing very well rather than
slipping off like it would on a flat
leaf collard leaf type
so cur kayla's a little bit of a generic
term because it can cross species but
essentially
kale is in four primary groups i would
say it's in the type curl boracal type
it's in the uh savoy crinkle leaf uh
toscano or lacinato type
you have the flat leaf types which
include the forage kales thousand-headed
kale
and the collards and then
less common you have the
the jagged leaf types you can get these
in the olyraciotypes and i've been
working on them certainly
uh like fez uh but most of these are the
russian and siberian types which are
actually uh brass canapus not brassica
or
so the cat the salad types which are
more fit in with modern markets really
form in with the curl and the savoy that
you get from
the curly leaf and the toscano leaf
types
the market classes
also um seem to vary
it's not that they have better or worse
nutrition they have different nutrition
this is a preliminary study um hannah
sweygarden who was a recent phd student
and
carl sams from the
analysis for these down in tennessee
uh but they did give indications that
collards tend to be
higher in the
glucosinolate
categories
compared to the
curly and toscano types
and the
toscano and curly types tend to be
higher in the carotenoids than the
collar types
so
with among these market classes you have
different colors different leaf
morphologies
different nutrition levels and you can
create a type of a fusion breeder where
you can move some of these
characteristics among the traditional
market classes to
provide some new market opportunities
the
effort on leaf color has fallen
basically into the aesthetic realm and
the nutrition realm and is focused on
the
the more green golden green types and
the anthocyanin types
and
this gives nutrition
via the
polyphenolics and the anthocyanins and
via the carotenoids and the
glucosinolates just in the regular
leaf types of brassicas of course
part of it is
diversifying from a fairly limited
market class
to scholar
it's characterized as having this dark
blue green type as many kales a lot of
people see this as high levels of
nutrition
where a lot of the standard market
classes are more this golden green type
um
remain arugula etc so part of it's
keeping the crunch and dressing holding
characteristics of the toscano but
moving it into perhaps more mainstream
market classes and even focusing on
these deep purple or purple vein kale
types in those categories
the toscano cal has a number of benefits
it's it's more self-compatible than the
curly kale so it's a little bit easier
to work with in a breeding program
especially if you're looking to develop
things like cms hybrids so
these toscano kales have been crossed
out to multiple brassica species over
the last 10 years and
a diverse set has basically been
developed of inbred lines
during that time we've also developed
a cms line that shows good
complementation in hybrid production
as a as a standard to
do complementation tests of
tuscan pollinators
uh we've also been
selecting the savoy type and a sort of
toscana collard type of background
amongst breeding lines which you can see
has much more vigor than this
toscano leaf in this image
so in 2020
uh 27
breeding lines in red lines
uh were identified that ranged in leaf
shape with texture leaf color from
golden to purple
to bright green
and they were all used as pollinators
onto a common
cms
seed parent at the same time this cmsc
period was increased with the maintainer
with the seed company to develop a
million or so seeds in
preparation for
seed production
so these 27 hybrids were produced and
now we're identifying
based on vigor
appearance and uniformity
a range of leaf types the color
typically is intermediate
to the two parents the
cms um
see parent and the pollinators are on
the right
so this is an example of a
a selection of the blue green leaf type
with the tkp2
then if we were to use the bright green
tkp 16
with the blue green we end up with more
of a dark green look
if we use a
golden pollinator
we end up with a a bright green or a
golden green color
and if we use a purple pollinator we end
up with a
purple leaf tuscan and of course
these all share they're all half hazards
because they all share the parents and
so
they will have some commonality with
their
production and maturity and appearance
just based on that criteria
so
that's the work that's currently in
progress and we're also of course
starting to look at toscano college and
this is where we backtrack to the
african efforts perhaps
um a lot of sakura wiki has more of this
flat leaf herbaceous type so the shelf
life is very limited to just a few hours
before it has to be used of course
when you get this avoid type into both
parents that are being combined
uh in this case an inbred of uh survivor
crossed to a
bright green
tuscan
you can see how they can complement one
another to to really get bigger that's
five times what the inbred parent says
and provide a very nice
looking product that's going to cook
down better to a larger amount
and going to have a lot more shelf
stability in the marketplace and there's
already a
hybrid in eastern africa we've found me
from east african seats that has a
little bit of survive so
that's
already been shown to be popular in the
market the savoy is more like the
leaf type up here
so the effort now is to really
try and move a lot of these
purple and golden leaf traits across the
brassica market classes
and toscano has been a
start of course
um it's a
it's something that needs various steps
you need to select the best golden types
you need to get them into the right
plant types then you need to do the cms
conversion
so once you get that into two parents to
complement one another you can actually
get some very nice
materials
uh we're doing a cms conversion of tkp18
right now to be able to develop this and
anecdotally what we find from these
types of products is we hear that
they're um
more tender not as bitter
attractive
and so they have different
market class characteristics that can be
appealing to
different groups perhaps even the
southeast
colored
consumers
the
toscano is the going to be the first
group that's coming out of course the
traditional toscano is the blue green
uh but moving the purple vein into a um
dark
green or blue-green leaf
currently moving it also into the golden
green leaf
it ultimately provides the
um
a diverse set
of toscano types and next-gen set so to
speak
which
can be half sims or very close uh so can
have similar horticultural
characteristics and then can be chopped
up to produce sort of rainbow lacinata
sound mixes for example or used of
course in the baby green sets as
masonito tends to be a
tuscan tuscan tends to be a very good
seed producer
so this has come through the combination
of multiple efforts and
funding sources but most importantly the
ability to
work with some flexibility as a breeder
without being
tied into
very rigid criteria
and so that's just an overview of my
next-gen toscana work and if anybody has
any questions i'll be happy to answer
them via the zoom or via email
thank you very much